i'm going to speak with you about five
open source security tools i think that
all developers should know about
so first thing first
most of the developers that i know
doesn't really care about security at
least not first thing right
so when they say about if their code is
secured
most of the time they say not me i don't
know how
or something else doesn't really
relevant
and so why does developers need to know
about security tools
so we believe in a term it's a
relatively new term called minimum
viable minimum valuable security like
you have minimum viable product probably
you all know about it
so
we think that
like the product
it should be also in security you have
to start early don't wait for a breach
to happen or for the sister to come and
start asking questions or for the
company to have to
to do some compiling like sock 2 and
things like that you have to start as
early as they can and shift left so i'm
sorry i've heard it a lot of time in
this convention
so
i think that
this is the future for developers i mean
up until years ago if developers needed
dev teams uh devops team sorry to do
to start servers to do a lot of ops
operation now they can do it by
themselves they can raise lambdas
servers
whatever they need also in qa they need
they can create end-to-end tests by
themselves so i think the next thing is
security there are a lot of companies in
the recent years that are starting to do
this shift
and give the developers the power
to
secure their code
so
with a lot of power comes a lot of
overhead so
they have to do it iteratively
iteratively not doing all at once let's
say they didn't start early and the
program the project program is running
for years if they want to do it now more
secure
it can take them
a lot of months to do it
so we're talking about doing it
iteratively
next thing is
why do you need to secure so those are
just few
of the categories you need to secure you
need to secure data to protect from any
secrets to being leaked you have to
secure your libraries using the
infrastructure for co for a cloud
infrastructure and everything else your
containers and runtime scanning
so
how to choose
so i told you that indeed we want to
help developers use those security tools
so actually research and invested a lot
of time to research different tools in
different areas all the areas that i
showed you before and also in different
languages
and i would won't show you all the
spreadsheet with all the thousands of
points and i'll get only the three main
things you have to consider
so the first term
is accountability you're searching for a
dependency check for python start
looking for open source tool for it on
the web you get to github you see a
couple of
options so you have to check the stars
how many forces that is there's how many
watchers is it owned by something
someone private or by a big company even
a security company
does it have a lot of contributors does
it qualify by open ssf is it maintained
was the last update a year ago month ago
or days ago
and the licensing is it really free i
mean is it mit apache do you need do you
have any rate limit
you get only some of the data free but
then if you want to see explanation
about the the vulnerability you have to
pay
so
this is the first
first thing you have to check
okay
next thing up is usability so
this this one gets even trickier because
here you have all the data you can
search everything now you really have to
try it
so try it
you can if it's got a good documentation
you can run it locally you can maybe use
the dockerfile to run it maybe it has
some plugins to ide or ci actions in
github or jenkins
does it configurable does it need files
or flags to run it is it easy to add all
those flags
and how does it output looks like is it
the json file that you can handle
technically
and is it easy to understand all the all
the parameters like if it found
vulnerability does it show you what it
is and explain all the
and
details
last part is actually the hardest part
you have to actually run it and see the
results so you can test it on your own
repos on go triples so here we have
actually some cyber security expert
better than i am that actually check
them on on go triples and see if it has
a lot of false positive or false
negative
and that's the severity level is
accurate i mean maybe it shows
everything is critical but some of them
is low so it's also a lot of overhead to
the
developers does it have a good coverage
it can be on file types or
or maybe just more more databases that
it connects to and get more cvs
so
that's
that was the part and now after we
discussed about why what and how let's
start and
deep dive to each one of them so secret
detection
okay
talking a bit fast we'll slow down
okay so secret detection mission
is to find secrets
passwords even credit card numbers api
tokens
all kind of secrets that you don't want
to get to the web so
by the raise of hand who knows someone
else that pushed a secret to github
someone else not you okay
so it happens all the time
not to me of course someone i know
and we checked three different tools for
secret detection so we checked git leaks
actually a couple of days ago we
announced that it's going to be a
company it was by zachary smith
and it's going to be git leaks company
so i updated it
we checked detect secrets by help and
git secrets by aws all our great tools
and we did all the checks that we talked
about and we decided to go with git
licks we gave you the page from github
you can see it has a lot of watching and
forks and so many stars
and it was updated a couple of weeks ago
you can run it
all so many app options i mean
directly for your computer it has the ci
action i actually think that now the ci
action you have to pay for now that it
became a company but you can still run
it free locally and in docker file
and it has a good config file that you
can add more rules more regex if you
have secrets that you know how they look
like
it's very accurate we saw that it found
a lot of our secret in our grocery pos
not the real secrets of course we don't
have them
and it runs all multi on all file types
that we checked can be a text file it
can be python file terraform files
everything
and it founds a lot of secrets from
different types i mean aws account keys
github account keys all sorts of secrets
so i'll show you just an example of how
it looks like
so
this is an access key for aws
and if you run it simply writing the
command at the top you it found the
secret and it also tells you the rule
type so this one is aws access token
great
okay the second category is dependency
check
so what's the mission to detect open
source component with known
vulnerabilities even it's the first
packages to use or even deeper packages
that they use
themselves so we checked here
specifically for python where design
partners zero for our company so we were
right in python so we checked on python
and we checked safety by pi up jake by
sonotype and
a dependency check of owasp all were
very good
and we chose
owasp
also it's very very common tool to use
it's also
passing the open ssf
it's very update
then
probably 12 days ago since i took the
screenshot
and you can run it also in docker file
from the terminal that's a genkis plugin
i put it in purple because i don't want
to put in red so you don't think it's
vulnerability
but
not such a good thing it doesn't find
the dependency tree so for python it
doesn't really matter but the dependency
check also can run on node and on golang
and they they can find you a
[Music]
library that you use deeper but it
doesn't show you the tree of what was
the first
external
library that you use
so you have to use some other tools to
get the tree and tend to cross between
the the results
and
it's very accurate it checks the
vulnerabilities both in nvd data and oss
index
it runs for python it runs actually not
only on the requests a requirement sorry
also run some zip file or metadata file
other places that can have python
dependencies
and it runs as i said on multiple
languages and not only python
some of them are actually are in
experimental mode so actually for go we
choose nancy and i won't discuss about
it but it's such a cute logo so i put it
here
and
so yeah you have to really check for
each language that you use if it's good
for it or not
for python we found out that yes but not
not so for other languages it depends
and they keep processing it and keep
updating it we will see updates all the
time
okay so an example
i have this big requirements file with
only one library
requests
and you see all the output but i'll zoom
in
and so it found that it has a
vulnerability inside it it tells you the
cv from oss index
and it even gets a score
and what happens with this package
actually this one sums it up
insufficiently protected credentials
and can even go to the site and get more
data
from oss index
and for more site
cool
so
point number three infrastructure
misconfiguration so what's the mission
here
so we want to detect misconfiguration in
infrastructures code before it hits the
sky reach the cloud it can be
misconfigured miss missing encryptions
to broad permissions
maybe you are not logging which is
actually essential in security or not
using other mandatory uh things you
should use you have some default ports
or any other default values that you
shouldn't
use i like to check the picture
it tells me to slow down so it's okay
okay so we checked tfsec by aqua kicks
by check marks and chekhov by palo alto
i think all of a
booth here upstairs
all were very very good tools and it was
really hard to choose we go with kicks
after a lot of testing
and also very very
strong tool by by check marks
very updatable stars and everything
and it can run on multiple file types it
runs on turf all files for the aws cloud
formation jsons
for azure and
google cloud as well
it has powerful queries i think more
than 2000 queries you can see on the
website that you run then scan and check
if there is a vulnerability in your code
it does a nightly build so it can get
updates all the time
and the note 5 will scan is actually a
line
from their output so
usually when you run it you get a json
file with all the data and all the
vulnerabilities even if it didn't find
anything but if there weren't files to
scan meaning there were json files but
non-cloudformation.json it gets you a
text file with this output so
it's not the only case there are some
kind of case when it not gets you the
output you're looking for so you have to
handle it yourself
and here's an example
so this is amazon elastic block store
and this is the config for it and
i'll zoom in
found you the severity medium medium
level and
it's essential to use as encryption and
it's not enabled
i want to add something else
compared to to check of which was also
good and also gave us a lot of result
chekhov didn't give us the severity
level and this can be very overwhelming
to get 2000 vulnerabilities without any
severity level you don't know which one
are more critical than the others so
this is one of the reasons that we
choose kicks and not checkup
okay
but both have very good false positive
and false negative
scores
okay container scanning
so the mission to find vulnerabilities
in your containers images
and the docker files so we tested trivia
by aqua clear and encore
and we chose to go with trevi
also they have a boot upstairs i think
of aqua
also a lot of stars and forks and it's
very updatable
maintainable
and it's very very easy to use
you straight out of the box
it's very accurate it runs multiple
packages if your docker file runs in
different
packages
and it also detects secrets and
infrastructures as code vulnerability so
why is this line in purple because
for trivia it's good it does a lot of
things but actually it is better for
docker files and we use the other tools
for secrets and for infrastructure as
code so if we use trivia as it is we
will get actually duplicated findings
and vulnerabilities from
from all the tools so you have to
configure what you want to get from each
tool if it is configurable
so i didn't add the docker file but i
ran it on on a docker it find three
vulnerabilities
two of them is because buffer overflow
uh
because of a long path name
and the last one is
runtime
so
runtime scanning you need to check your
web application even your apis
while they're live up and running
it's also called dust
so we checked between zap by os
foundation
nikto and
kini i think actually they are already
deprecated
and zap is a well-known tool i hope you
already know i've heard about it i think
it's running for
12 years now
and
it's very
i mean gets a lot of releases a lot of
contributors passes the openos ossf open
ssf
it can be run in two types full scan
docker you can actually install it
install it as an application and it has
a ui and you can figure everything
it's very very
extensible so it's got a marketplace
it's got a lot of plugins so if you want
to deep dive in it there's a lot of work
you should do to add more plugins and to
use it
better
and it's very accurate it has a lot of
feature it checks for sql injection
broken access cross-site scripting it
does fuzzing
authorized and unauthorized access
so many many tools
and many things it can check
okay so here's just an example of
finding that that it found
and
the content security policy the header
is not set and it explains you the
reason why it's a problem it gets a risk
score
i don't know why it's both low and
medium
okay
so
i'll show you a quick demo of using only
four of the tools the first one
and
what can go wrong
oops
okay so
here i have
my repo it's public
and it's got a terraform file
using dynamodb
i have your docker file
with some passwords in it
we've got a python file to run
everything
and requirements
with some vulnerabilities
okay
so just configured
a github workflow called it security
demo
and you can see here i will zoom in
okay
so i just wrote all the tools that we
discussed about
it runs parallelly in different jobs so
secret detection this is all it has to
take in order to run actually it runs
only on the less commit unlike the
others we checks all your different
branch i'll discuss about it later
and
dependency check so this is os
dependency check and everything you have
to pass it in order to run
so this is for
running on python
okay
infrastructure is code this is kicks
running on the terraform file
i told you it can run also in other file
jsons and a lot of things they actually
also added option to run on docker so
you need to check it again compared to
trivi
but still we're using trivia for
checking containers
and that's about it okay
so
i will add a github token
because i love secrets
i saved it here
and i'll create a new branch
okay
so this is actually pushed my my changes
i don't have to create a pull request
and it started to run all the tools
you can go in
the meanwhile we'll create a pull
request
okay
so this is the secret scanner by git
licks
so you can see how it works and it found
lick was found
it tells you the rule it found out that
it's kid's a password this is just the
regex for how github secrets looks like
ghf and numbers
okay dependency check finished
okay
so you can see it found it ran a lot of
checks
and it tells you that it found the cv
you can go to the report also to find it
and they finish really by the order
and this is kicks and it found a lot of
things
of different severities iam access
analyzer not enabled
f3 bucket logging disabled
and
higher severities dynamo table not
encrypted
and a
failly so you can see it found a lot of
things
too high severities it gets your
conclusion at the end
and
last one it's still running
okay
so
part of the problem that some of them
can actually take long time actually i'm
surprised it's trivia usually it's more
kicks because it reaches database to get
information
and also dependency check it needs to be
updated all the time
and but let's give trivia some chance
thank you
okay okay so it took time because it
needs to update ddtv every once in a
while
and it downloaded the db
and it found four crit for hi sorry and
vulnerabilities
and it explains you the reason why
zooming
okay
so i'll go back to the slides
okay
so i show you how to run everything and
we discussed about
some difficult difficulties that we have
with them i mean not all of them
most of them are pretty accurate but you
have to
some takes time some have different
output files
so you have to handle each one of them
and see how to use it
i still recommend if you're not using
any of them and you're using python or
any other
tool that we discussed to try and see it
for yourself to just add him and see if
it find vulnerabilities
another issue is unlike git leaks they
run on all the default branch and find
all the findings since day one
and it also can be very overwhelming to
the developer to just write his small pr
i didn't want to see all the other files
that they didn't touch
so
widget actually want to do an
orchestration of those tools and to help
you use them very easy and much faster
and those are some of the tools that
we're running so it goes for different
languages and different technologies
polar for example is for running checks
checks to your aws
sorry aws cloud
same grep is for static analysis for
javascript bandits static analysis for
python
goes for go we discussed about the cute
logo of nancy
and
sorry and we also added branch
protection checking your branches at
github to see if you enabled branch
protection
and more other tools that we're using
ourselves
and
i'll show you our tool in a minute but
these are some screenshots
let's just see them
okay
okay so i've already enabled a plan let
me zoom in
so i want to check on my assets i want
to check
static analysis dependency checks
secrets
containers and infrastructures code you
have service catalog
to add more tools you can see by plans
if it's sock 2 or
several is top 10 by categories and you
can add more tools and more features
some of them we're still in beta mode by
the way so some of them are not
are not enabled but you can use most of
them
and i already committed the plan and i
already added my my repos
so
these are all the vulnerabilities i
already already had on my default
branches so we do think that in in these
pages not every developer will go and
look inside because this is more for a
security champion that wants to go
deeper and find old vulnerabilities and
he can decide what to do with them to
assign them to a team or to a person
but once someone
created a pr
so this is for the developer
we're actually telling him where he
added this time a secret where he added
vulnerability and we show it as a
comment in on the pr
and if we merge it anyway
it depends if they enabled branch
protection by us or not oh
sorry
so only then it will go
and appear here in the finding page
i'll give you time to run
and i think